um you at a certain point had to deal
with atlantic
and i remember you put out the record
with tay k and block boy jb right should
we play it on real ninety two three oh
my god how much they pay you for that
nothing no i just played it for you we
played it as a new join of the day yeah
it was cool it was a good one take it
very hard
i know i know that like they kind of had
pulled up
correct me if i'm wrong right there was
those old accusations that came out
and atlantic kind of washed their hands
of that situation we had like a one-year
contract with our one-year addition to
it where it's like an option to do
another year and after the first year
they basically
were like they just had like hell of
pressure being put on them by like
journalists and [ __ ] have just kept
hitting them up for [ __ ] comments how
do you feel about this yada yada and
it's like there's so much [ __ ]
bureaucracy in that [ __ ] that so much
like you know it's hard to make things
move you know like if they have like if
you have like the budget and the team
fully behind you it just ended up being
more trouble than it was worth because
they were dealing with all this weird
[ __ ] from journalists trying to get them
like to
basically they had like journalists
trying to get them to cut me off and
it's like we did that one record we did
like another record it was kind of
whatever i personally and i know it's
like convenient for me to say this some
people might think i'm lying i hated
everything about the experience it was
[ __ ] terrible i started to realize
like very early on that i didn't get the
deal that i could have got should have
got and that if i was really gonna do
this i wanted to do it my own way you
know like they were trying to sign an
artist i try to sign draco they're like
he's too gang related i'm like
well what the [ __ ] am i even doing here
then you know like this is not you know
like if you're gonna tell me that artist
being too gang
means i don't get to sign them what the
[ __ ] did you sign me for because that's
not i didn't like what year was that get
into this to do like some safe [ __ ] you
know that's not like i want to sign an
artist that i believe in and obviously
if i had signed draco my life would have
been full of many many headaches as a
result of it so they probably spared me
some some headaches but you know it's
just it wasn't really a good fit to be
honest i know how to do all that [ __ ] i
was gonna say like i just don't really
care because i don't really see
the value like the times that i've seen
an artist that we could sign and i
really started to conceive of how much
work it was gonna be
and how uncertain them becoming a big
star was
and then how much money i'm making doing
other things i just could not like do
the math that would the bandwidth that
you would have to put into it and i'm
already based on the risk so many things
and it's like a lot of times i just look
at my life and somebody comes with me a
business opportunity and i'm like that
is a great [ __ ] idea and i do not
have the time and there's no way like
you're gonna make if you do that right
you can make millions of dollars off
that idea
but i just don't i i really don't
believe that i'm going to be able to
invest myself in it you know